[Music]
this is an owl monkey and she's just a
baby let's see we gonna turn this way
honey no anger her when she's on my
carotid artery let's see here couldn't
hold up that little piece of fruit and
we'll see if we get a return look at
that I just made a kitty sound that's
how I attract let's see if we're gonna
turn it here okay right there you like
that now check out the eyeballs on this
owl this is the only nocturnal owl
species this is it you said owl I'm
sorry it's an owl monkey it's the only
nocturnal or not a wildlife expert area
it's the only nocturnal monkey species
it's called an owl monkey because of
those huge eyes and because they're
nocturnal they normally are eating
things like fruit oh look it's like he's
been up all night having Red Bull get
that term paper in this this species
though likes to eat insects and they're
so adept with their night vision and
their hands that they can actually
snatch flying insects right out of the
air in the pitch darkness in the South
American forests or they look at this
animal is it's like so finicky for an
animal from the wild about which nuts it
will eat okay that's
she tried to just borrow and she tried
to go into my hair and then and then
realize okay that's good but that's fine
that blood will dry okay you're okay
I got a reason on your shoulder I better
yes that's I keep this here for you Andy
all right well that'll keep my interest
through the show
you